يعتقد جمال هازوكي أن الرسائل التي
أرسلها للمعارض السعودي كانت
مخبأة في أمن الواتس آب
بدلاً من ذلك كانت الرسائل عبارة عن كتاب مفتوح ،
لذا كان الهاتف بأكمله مزعومًا من
قبل Pegasus قطعة قوية من
البرامج الضارة من إسرائيل
ومجموعة إدوارد سنودن في  وصف أول ظهور له على
الإطلاق بالفيديو في إسرائيل في
تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) شركة مثل
مجموعة ENSO هذه في عالم اليوم بناءً على
الأدلة التي لدينا أنها
الأسوأ في بيع أدوات السطو هذه
التي يتم
استخدامها حاليًا بنشاط لانتهاك حقوق الإنسان وأنت
أعرف نشطاء معارضين معارضين
، تعرفت على قوة
Pegasus عن غير قصد قبل عامين ،
تم اختراق هاتفك الآن ، لقد
حان عشر ثوانٍ ، وأظهر لي
خبراء الأمن المحمول عند نقطة تفتيش ، أحد
قادة العالم في مجال الأمن السيبراني ،
أنه يمكنهم اختراق هاتف باستخدام
نقرة واحدة للوصول الكامل إلى
كاميرا الميكروفون وبيانات البرامج الضارة
التي استخدموها كما يقولون كانت متشابهة  ar إلى
Pegasus ، كان مايكل شاولونج أحد خبراء الإنترنت وهو
مايكل شاولونج الذي أطلق أول شركة
ناشئة في عام 2010 عندما أدرك
التهديد المحتمل لبيغاسوس والبرامج المماثلة
حتى عندما رأوا البرنامج على
وجه التحديد وكالة إنفاذ القانون
التي اشترتها في الأصل
في الحالة التي  يريد هؤلاء الأشخاص إصابة
ما نعتبره كما هو مزعوم
في أهداف مشروعة ، لا
تتحكم NSO أو لا يمكنهم حقًا منع
مستخدمي مجموعة NSO مما يسمى
بالثغرات الأمنية المخفية في أيام الصفر على
الأجهزة المحمولة التي يمكن للقراصنة النخبة
استخدامها للوصول إلى  ركزت الأعمال
الداخلية للهاتف ومجموعة من الأشخاص دائمًا
على الأجهزة المحمولة.
أظهر مكالماتهم بكلب ألفا
في السوق مع سلسلة من أيام الصفر
التي يمكنهم استخدامها لاختراق الهاتف ما لم تقم
Apple أو Google بإصلاح هذا الخطأ الذي
تمنى 80 أو  يمكن أن يستمر هذا السوء
لسنوات عديدة ويمكن لـ NSO الاستمرار في بيع
البرامج القادرة على اجتياز
تلك الثغرات في البرنامج وفي
الواقع الهاتف
Apple و  د تعمل Google باستمرار
على إصلاح الأخطاء في وقت قريب من الصفر ، لكن كل
ميزة جديدة تقدم رمزًا جديدًا ونقاط ضعف جديدة.
ومواقع محاولة اختراق الهاتف لا حدود لها تقريبًا ،
لكنه يقول إن عددًا قليلاً نسبيًا من
الأشخاص لديهم الخبرة اللازمة
للعثور عليهم لتطويرها وربما
بيعها إذا قمت بسلسلة لذلك ، نعم
والزبائن موجودون هناك لشرائها ، نعم
هذا ليس كذلك ولكن هناك دائمًا  اطلب
أن يتغير العرض ولكن نعم سيكون هناك
دائمًا شخص ما لشرائها ،
وقد استفادت مجموعة NSO من هذا
الطلب شركة بملايين الدولارات
بمنتج قوي جعله المنتج
Pegasus NSO في قلب سلسلة من
الدعاوى القضائية من أماكن مثل  المكسيك
وقطر يزعمان أن استخدام البرمجيات الخبيثة
كما في حالة جمال كازوكي انتهك
القانون الدولي
أورين ليبرمان سي إن إن تل أبيب